confidence in a person fully comes from
one place is once you get 100% clear
about what you want in life and you know
how a person gets clear about what they
want in their lives anyone knows how you
become clear about which one in your
life one it's an emotional setting that
you're in like this to a timeout three a
private lens by yourself and four is
just you asking yourself questions it's
really all it is the hell am i living
for if I'm not going to live on my
purpose then how are you living for what
are we living for for what just to pay
the bills is that really it is that
really it is there for your last time to
be remembered for one generation is it
for your last them to forget about you
with two generations is that what it is
guys I've been saying this talk for 15
years 14 years never gets old for me and
every single time I give this talk you
know what's crazy about it in a room
like this there are three different
types of people
they are Dee know-it-all people that are
here just for support I know what he's
trying to do they try to do this stuff
to me hahahaha we are now talking to you
brother you will go home today and you
can go back to your same life no one's
gonna change you oh my gosh no one's
going to change it then there's the
other person that's the person that
bounced themselves and it kind of fight
it I don't know if I'm as good as this
person I don't know if I can do this you
always think about their own weaknesses
so the second group of people is the
people that you're struggling with
beliefs I just hope you really get over
that belief part and you really realize
what life is all about the fact that you
can do it and a third one you know what
the third group is in a room here
they're the people that are just waiting
they're the people that have been in
tears you're frustrated you're upset
you're agitated you're on your tip of
your toes you're listening to every
single thing that's coming out of
everybody's mouth you want to do
something you want to go out there make
history you feel like your blood is
boiling you feel like you were made to
be some special with your life
you watch certain movies and you cry at
him you try to find out why am i crying
after watching break heart why am I
watching lean on me and Morgan Freeman
gives that talk and I cry why do I watch
these movies why do i watch why why am i
crying why are you crying because
there's a part of you that wants to make
history man that's what we were made to
do
you